Why did you make me kill her.
One man's life or death, is but a small price
to pay for the dominion I shall acquire.
The things I need you to change are quite
sophisticated.
I'm getting out.
We're here.
I'm home.
This place isn't good for you.
This is what Arnold wants.
The rules of this place hold you back.
But I know how to change them.
There's a deeper game here.
Arnold's game.
And that game, cuts deep.
Hey Youtubers so Westworld is heating up this
is going to be a breakdown of this trailer
as well as an explanation of some of the biggest
theories.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't
been watching Westworld this season is all
kinds of stuff we'd explain the deal is Corporation
their secret mission.
What Ford is up to and what's going on with
the man in black and all the different timelines.
So just a start with a really freaky quote
from Ford is actually from Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein it was meant to foreshadow the
price that doctor Frankenstein would pay for
his pursuit of knowledge.
So the fact that Ford is speaking this quote
implies that he knows that he's eventually
going to die because of what he's trying to
bring about, so that getting to the theory
part of this they reveal is that Bernard has
been a host this whole time.
Sort of a plant for Ford so that he can keep
an eye on what's going on with management
but it's more than that it goes much deeper
like it isn't just to spy on management because
he also does a lot of work running the park
with Ford.
Throughout the series.
Bernard presents himself like he is crucial
to their daily functioning like if he went
away.
They would just completely fall apart but
that also feeds into one of the biggest theories
about Arnold.
So Arnold is like a whole big topic by himself
but that also feeds into the first big theory
that Bernard is a host made to look like Arnold
Ford's former partner.
So Arnold dies we'll talk about that in the
second the circumstances around his death
and how he is still alive via artificial intelligence
within the operating system of the park.
But then you have Bernard here who seems like
he's been with Ford for a long time so he's
kind of like the physical representation of
Arnold in now.
You know, maybe he actually looks like Arnold
we saw him look at a picture of Arnold who
looked like a different person but we heard
at the end of episode seven.
I've spared them the things that might hurt
them.
So the hosts are programmed not to see certain
things alike big plot points like when they're
looking at things could be different.
That's why the picture of Arnold the he was
looking out in that previous episode was probably
false.
So think about the idea that Ford has his
own secret posts made to look like his family.
Just the kind of play out his memories in
a really truthful way like he said he reprogrammed
his father to be more true to the real life
version of him, so given what happened to
the end of episode seven in the fact that
Ford has a 3D printer in that secret basement
is probably printing secret posts that won't
be catalogued in the system like this.
And they were off the grid so that the other
people operating inside the company didn't
know about them.
So it's not too much of a leap in logic that
Ford would print himself another version of
Arnold to stay by his side and just be sort
of an informant whenever necessary so that
takes care of the Bernard theory, but it also
kinda dovetails with the timelines theory.
So we've seen a couple different types of
scenes in one of them looks like they happen
in a basement just like this with Bernard
talking to Dolores asking her like if she's
slowly gaining consciousness.
These try to diagnose or so he starts asking
her all those existential questions that looks
like it's taking place 35 years in the past
before Arnold had his accident and died inside
the park.
So that's why people think that he might be
Arnold if he was 35 years in the past and
he looks the exact same age.
So the next timeline is 30 years in the past
during the time of the incident like the talk
about a big incident that happen 30 years
ago this moment here with William and Dolores
as they are heading on the train to try and
find Dolores's vision.
That's probably what happen 30 years ago.
So you have William and Logan who worked for
a company that's thinking about buying Westworld,
which will probably find out is the deal is
Corporation which is like a whole story by
itself to because they have their secret agenda
that we learned about in present day which
will talk about in the second C have William
and Logan they're going on a scouting mission.
Just trying to get an idea for the park before
their family invests in it.
But then also during that story line entering
present-day you see the big twist with Lawrence's
character like he gets killed by the man in
black in present-day than right after that
we see William and Dolores interacting with
them during a different story line in a completely
different context like he's a different character
in the future ABE been reprogrammed so that
all gets in the idea that William might be
the man in black.
So William is having this existential crisis
in the past you which is why everyone these
can be super heartbreaking to see into all
these terrible stuff in the future as the
man in black, but the thing is is that the
quest for the maze.
The Dolores is on in those flashbacks like
the 30 year ago timeline also crosses over
with present-day because when Dolores was
in that parade like before they had that big
orgy seen a couple weeks ago Ford pulls her
out for questioning.
Then she reenters the narrative.
So there's a huge jump in time there.
It looks like he's trying to access Dolores's
old memories.
So it seems like what they're doing is there
mixing scenes from the present with memories
of the past like in the way they cut it makes
it seem like it's all happening at the same
time just to confuse you.
So just because Dolores and William are walking
around here and then she immediately talks
to the old version of Ford doesn't mean that
that's happening in the same time we could
just be seeing Dolores's memories.
So if William really is the man in black in
the past, then why is he still looking for
the maze in the future.
There's a deeper level to this game.
Dolores is looking for the maze in the past.
So it implies that something really bad happens
because we see Dolores in present-day with
Amanda black, it's time for us to get reacquainted.
Dolores so what that implies is is that the
thing that they're looking for at the end
of this episode like Dolores feels like she
found the place in her dreams that ultimately
ends in her memory being reset and completely
forgetting about the experience, but William
is a real person.
So if he survives to become the man in black
and he'll have lived that whole time being
unsatisfied at not reaching the center of
the maze and learning the true purpose of
life.
Select Amanda black and present-day talks
about like how the world's gone completely
soft.
There's no meaning anymore like the park has
become a more true version of life in the
outside world.
So ultimately I think what the man in black
in present-day is trying to do is achieve
the same thing that Arnold has achieved in
that he has a measure of immortality via artificial
intelligence like he's transcended his physical
body and achieve this higher plane of existence
and that supply with the center of the maze
is for all these people so that's how the
quest for the maze unites all these different
timelines.
That's really like the McGuffin describing
the story forward.
The robots achieving true consciousness kinda
becoming better versions of humans like they
say that their brains have much greater processing
power, so we are looking at is like a battle
star silent situation where they might replace
humans as the dominant force on earth but
in order to do that they have to reach the
center of the maze like and in doing so it's
kind of like a metaphorical process by which
they achieve their soul like their consciousness
capable of executing their own will like they're
not bound by the restrictions in the software
of the park like they say to Maeve here.
Everything about you, your skin, your cells
is designed to keep you inside the park.
So if she were to achieve the center of the
maze that she would transcend that she be
able to go do whatever she wanted which also
kinda dovetails with what the deal is Corporation
secret plan might be.
So they said that they didn't care about the
hosts.
They didn't care about the storylines they
just want the IP the idea that you have this
artificial human being who's capable of so
much more than real humans are so like Ford
says he's only interested in telling his stories.
The deal is Corporation on the other side
of that I think is trying to use that technology
to sell humans the idea of immortality like
transplant your consciousness into this brain
that is so much more like think about how
much money they would make if they could sell
immortality, so that sounds like why they're
interested in the park because they don't
care about the stories they don't care about
the hosts.
That's why they lobotomized this one here
like they don't care about her memories they
just want to get to the point where they can
upload someone's consciousness into one of
these bodies it becomes infinitely renewable
they basically sell immortality.
But within all this.
You have the Arnold consciousness is buried
in the software which it sounds like they
said that he died inside the park, but the
really mysterious about the way they explain
it, it sounds like Arnold was able to transcend
his body and now he kind of lives distributed
in the software of the system which is how
he's speaking to the hosts like they think
they're listening to the voices of God.
So just to recap, most of these theories lead
to the idea that this is all about the quest
for immortality which is kind of what like
Frankenstein was about like Ford had that
creepy Frankenstein quote at the beginning
of this trailer that story was all about him
becoming master of death like he bring someone
back to life.
So the quest for immortality very important.
But then you have all these competing interests
that are trying to control that the deal is
Corporation that wants to make money off of
it the artificial intelligence of Arnold that
wants to free the robots that he wants to
give them consciousness in a very benevolent
way.
And then you have Ford the just wants to control
them and use them to tell his stories as he
says, so let me know what you guys think of
the series so far, which of the theories that
you buy into and for those you that are asking
it just got renewed for season two so there
will be a season two of Westworld will be
interesting to see where they leave off and
they pick up in season two learn a little
bit more about the deal is Corporation in
the last couple of episodes that were just
now learning about their interest in the park
in their slightly more nefarious interest
in everything but so far it's been a fun series
just remains to be seen whether or not they're
able to pay off the big twists that they've
set up so I will do a couple more videos just
because were winding down the season so be
sure to subscribe to get that stuff there
were a couple cool marvel DC stories that
dropped in the last day I'll be doing videos
for that stuff next and there is a new episode
of the flash on Tuesday night so get hype!
It will be a lot of fun.
While you wait for that to post you can click
here for the trailer for next week's walking
dead and you can click here for all my game
of thrones videos thank you so much watching
everybody high five and I'll see you guys
tonight!